the omicron variant was first discovered
in south africa
and it's now spreading rapidly around
the world so what can south africa's
real world experience tell us about the
way omicron will behave in the uk
variant
b11529 was first spotted in early
november by lab technicians in pretoria
and that discovery would trigger a
global panic the uk health security
agency is raising concerns about a newly
identified variant the variant was
heavily mutated and scientists worried
these mutations would make it more
infectious and more dangerous than the
last dominant strain
[Music]
omicron's ability to infect large
numbers of people in south africa has
already been established its
transmissibility has been demonstrated
through covet tests performed in the
private and public sector
but most south africans don't get tested
when they're sick the tests are too
expensive
however there is a wealth of anecdotal
evidence about the infectious nature of
this strain
in places like alexandria township in
johannesburg the variant is now surging
through the community have you got a
sense for how many people have been
infected here
a lot of people i mean on a daily basis
i interact with around 100 to 200 people
majority of those people were all saying
that they have flu
it is more difficult to assess the
severity of omicron
although the south african experience is
providing important clues well i've had
a
headache blocked nose
wasn't too runny
i've been coughing on a scale of one to
ten for severity
one particularly
a four honestly before because it wasn't
that bad pretoria's steve biko academic
hospital is located at the epicentre of
this outbreak and staff have made a
series of important observations
there are fewer people exhibiting the
most serious symptoms and covert
patients are less likely to need oxygen
or ventilators those infected with
omicron tend to spend less time in
hospital in comparison with other
variants
all of this has given staff some room
for optimism right now we have 40
patients
either covert positive or waiting for
their results
but the difference this time around is
that the majority of these patients are
not here because of a severe covered
pneumonia scientists say vaccines like
the pfizer jab should prevent severe
disease or death
and that's good news for britain where
the majority of people have been
vaccinated
but it's bad news for south africa where
less than a third have been jabbed
still scientific surveys show around 60
percent of south africans have developed
antibodies after catching earlier
strains of covet
and this could explain why some people
who've been infected by omicron have not
experienced the most severe forms of the
disease
was pleasantly surprised actually most
of the patients were were breathing
normally on room air two-thirds of them
so the picture could change
but you know what certainly is that
there is a difference
this time around compared to the
previous three waves
the pandemic has ushered in 18 months of
pain for south africa
and omicron's arrival makes it worse
after south african scientists
identified this variant of concern
many countries implemented travel bans
which were designed to cut south africa
off and that's damaged an economy in
desperate need of tourist dollars and
general investment and it's angered
large swathes of the population
however after four waves of infection
over the past 18 months this country has
the experience and the experts to see it
through
2018